so let's say you want to host a drag
time story hour with seven-year-olds you
obviously can use your public library
for that but you can't read a book about
God at a public library and the actor
Kirk Cameron just learned that dozens of
public libraries refuse to give him a
slot to speak to kids about his new
faith-based book called as you grow one
Rhode Island library told him quote we
are a very queer friendly Library our
messaging does not align
okay Kurt Cameron joins us thank her
thanks so much for coming on
um so they wouldn't let you read this
book this book was banned in libraries
how controversial is this book
foreign
well it's a book that teaches biblical
wisdom through the seasons of life to
children and the value of growing the
fruit of the spirit like love joy
kindness patience gentleness
self-control and I wanted to do a book
reading at a public library and I was
denied by over 50 woke libraries that
have hosted drag queens story hours one
of the most outrageous denials was
Alameda County Public Library that said
they didn't want that book teaching kids
biblical values
while at the same time they're hosting a
gender name change clinic tomorrow
and I'm thinking wow if we're so
committed to diversity why am I being
excluded why can't I use your facility
to read my book you're a library
well yeah
um so we began the show with a story
about how the president of Ukraine has
banned a Christian religion in Ukraine
and then we get to your story where the
libraries ban your book so the thread
here appears to be fear and hatred of
Christianity why do you think a religion
based on peace and tolerance turning the
other cheek not showing vengeance is so
scary
well I my understanding of history is
that the family and the church are two
great pillars of Western civilization
and those two things need to be removed
and taken out of the way in order to
fundamentally change the power structure
and the moral value code of the nation
and that's why parents are fighting back
in fact Tucker hundreds of parents and
Librarians are now emailing us saying we
want your book and we want to host our
own Brave book story hour in our Public
Library so here's my call to action I
want every parent and every grandparent
in America to get their favorite
children's storybook my book or other
Brave books or a book of the Bible call
your local public library that has
hosted a drag queen Story Hour and say
I'd like the chance to read my book in
the library and if they say no they're
likely breaking the law and violating
the Constitution and they can contact
bravebooks.com we'll give them free
books and all that they need to turn
that denial into a Revival in their
community
I think the posture that you're taking
which is gentle and calm and brave and
persistent something I personally can
learn from less outrage more rational
response and I think that really works
and I hope that you inspire other people
to do the same tell your story don't get
mad be honest thank you
I thank you I think you're right uh
Tucker and and and to Christians
particularly we often get told no in the
Public Square we go home with our tail
between our legs crying in our
Chick-fil-A soup waiting for the Rapture
rather than getting on the offense and
saying let's invest in our children and
teach them the values we want them to
learn
amen I complete I completely agree with
that and the way you're doing it is the
way to do it I appreciate it Kirk
Cameron thanks
thank you Tucker subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight